what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i am going
to be reacting to different advice that
i saw on tick tock before i start don't
forget to subscribe to the channel and
bring that notification bell that way
you're going to be notified of my daily
videos
you're stupid oh wait wait hold on sorry
bastard why isn't it possible it's just
not why not you stupid bastard okay so
when you ask your girlfriend to take
down the photos of her and her ex on
insta and she says it's not possible
okay guys
do not go up after a girl that still has
pictures of her and her ex on her
instagram um
she's clearly not over him
and especially oh my gosh especially if
she's not willing to take them down for
you it's it's it takes two seconds um if
she's not willing to take down pictures
of her and her ex she's clearly not over
it she clearly looks at you as a second
choice and don't put up with that you're
kings you deserve better
that's me i'm not gonna lie i look
gorgeous
and of course i'll get the attention i
get the likes the views and people
telling me how beautiful i am physically
right
but not all attention is good attention
however there is more to me than just
the physical appearance it's my kind
heart it's my good spirit it's positive
vibes great energy and just overall an
amazing person inside and out
i definitely agree with what she said
about not all attention is good
attention i think that's a mistake a lot
of young girls make
is they really like when you're young
you're overwhelmed with male attention
very quickly and very fast and you're
very young so you don't have the wisdom
and maturity to know what to do with it
so i see a lot of young girls showing
off their body
wearing shorts where their butt is out
and it gets them attention but what what
kind of attention do you want
um so i agree with that part see i want
folks to love me for who i am not for
what you just see
see ladies if you show yourself half
naked or always dressed up with tight
fitted clothes a man is going to look
he's a man that's what they're going to
do but that doesn't mean that they want
you at the end of the day they want a
queen they want somebody that is going
to be a freak in the bedroom but be
classy in the streets
now all men want their goodies to be
shown for the world to see
okay
that's very true like i
i can't i've never met a guy that says
wow i hope my girlfriend
posts some more naked pictures on
instagram i know some that put up with
it and deal with it but that prefer it
no
um so now this girl right there is going
to respond
all i'm saying is that if you want a man
to treat you like a queen you have to
start by treating yourself like one
first no you know what i got a question
for women like you do y'all go to the
store and distinctively pick out outfits
for male validation when you are
yeah
i mean
yeah
when i when i go shopping i definitely
think about would my boyfriend like this
outfit i want him to think i'm hot
yeah
shopping do you think oh yeah this is
gonna make me look like a real boss this
is gonna let this man know i got respect
for myself is is that what y'all are
doing
yeah sort of yeah just because you dress
for male validation that does not mean
the rest of us do clearly like look at
this clearly
let's rewind how about we stop thinking
that women are dressing for men
why can't y'all understand whether we
are i mean i think
it's usually pretty obvious if you're
not and this is coming from a tomboy i
do not dress up often
i do not
but
if i'm going on a date with my boyfriend
or i want to represent myself online
yeah i'm i'm not going to show my butt
because i want to talk about
and i could mind you i could but no i
want to talk about ideas
dressing modestly or whether we're
dressing provocatively can y'all just
leave it at the fact that maybe we are
doing it for ourselves i know it's a
concept a lot of y'all don't want to
believe or don't want to understand but
start believing and the fact that you
refer to our body i'm not even going to
lie there is no one other than yourself
that could have done that eyebrow that
like
i'm sorry you clearly did that for
yourself ma'am buddies as a man's
goodies are you serious i do not sign
over the deed to my body when i get in a
relationship i am still an individual no
isn't that like what a relationship is
like he's the only one that has access
okay never mind and for the life of god
jesus mary and the lambs stop making it
seem like men are going to respect you
more when you dress modestly a man that
they do
oh my gosh they totally do i mean you'll
get more attention if you dress
provocatively i mean if you got a good
body you might
you might not get the
you may not get that attention if you
don't to be honest but yeah you
absolutely do
respects women will respect women see
you the kind of person to think it's
okay for you to work for a man's respect
the way that y'all are indirectly and
subconsciously signing on to the idea
that we have to work to get respected
that we
okay i'm sorry
you do have to work and you do have to
work to get respected and the thing is
you can't
you cannot um
just expect people that don't know you
to respect you like why on earth would i
respect someone that i don't know
your actions i mean i give you like
everyone a basic level of respect just
because you're a human being like i'm
not gonna go punch you in the face for
no reason but do i have to respect your
ideas the way you dress do i have to
respect any of that
no i don't
you have to do certain things in order
for men to respect us that we have to
dress modestly for men to respect us i
don't think you understand how much of a
disservice you're doing to all women but
also to yourself because i'm a woman
[Music]
i'm not
i agree
i hate it when women speak for all women
you don't speak for me lady with red
eyebrows because guess what women that
dress modestly women that cover
themselves they still get over
sexualized so you can refer to your body
as goodies for a man what is over
sexualized
like define over-sexualized i
because if a woman's wearing a sundress
she's more likely to be looked at as
beautiful than hot
like what type of attention do you want
you could do everything you want for
male validation [ __ ] when you go
shopping and you doing it for tom dick
and harry that's fine but leave us out
of it why is it our fault that men can't
see past the physical if a man you you
you
lady you could have just saw this video
and kept scrolling
like you she like she's saying her ideas
and is that shallow i don't want to deal
with him but somehow you've signed on to
the misogynistic idea that that's our
responsibility don't hit whenever
whenever
a girl says
misogynistic
i literally
usually think she's a little crazy
because
i don't buy into all that we have it so
good as as women we have it so good
and we do not appreciate it paint
yourself red and green and go sit in the
strawberry patch to get picked cause
obviously that's what you want
yeah
i want to get married so i want to be
picked by someone god damn into the
first installment of things i do to [ __ ]
with men's heads on purpose
let me just first start out by saying um
[Music]
i know this is [ __ ] up and
hold on i'm gonna put the
oh wait hold up okay
yeah that's all i know it's [ __ ] up
these are just things that i've started
doing
and
i've realized that it really okay i know
it was back and forth she's saying this
is what she does to mess with guys hats
books with their heads
and if you're trying to play the game
which let's be honest if you're single
and you're in these streets you are
so it just what game
look at what do you win
do you
do you want to win a guy
but you said you had to mess with him
in order to get him to date you is that
what you want
just helps you you know what i mean
okay the first thing is private story
and um
this is just
you know it's a classic you make a
private story you name it the exact same
thing as your regular private story and
you only
put one person being the guy that you're
trying to [ __ ] with or two or three like
you know however many you're trying to
[ __ ] with at one time
and you post
maybe it's a risque photo
maybe it's a meme you don't want to
embarrass yourself on your actual
private story so you're doing this just
so they can see it
we love this next one is call them by
their first name
um men love this i don't know why
or you could do like a little pet name
like say if his name is like dylan or
something you could do dill like dyl
like oh still
i don't know guys like that it's weird
okay this one's fine
calling them by their first name
isn't that just
what you do and i love to send a
snapchat message and then delete it
before they can even see it and then
whenever they message you and they're
like what did you send and you're like
what are you talking about they're like
it says that you deleted something just
don't even reply
also this isn't purposeful but i
literally can't remember anything like
this is actually really sad i went to
this guy's house a couple weeks ago
and he was like
talking to me and i was like oh yeah
what high school did you go to and he
looked at me and he was like i told you
this
i was like
i forgot
so tell me again
when
okay number one i have a terrible memory
so i've probably done something like i
know i've done something like that and
two i don't understand what the snapchat
would even do
like what let me know in the comments
what do you think that would do
a man is pissing me off
i like to call them bud
or pal
or anything like that it just pisses
them off
and then this is another classic you
just type on snapchat
and then don't send anything
if they like you at all they'll like
message you and be like
you were typing
you're like that was an accident
what
okay ladies if you want to see how to
waste time 101 follow those tips
but if you actually want a long-term
relationship i suggest
not doing those things and being as to
the point and nice as you possibly can
um even my boyfriend now when i asked
him like what made me stand out out of
all the other girls he was talking to he
told me it was because you were so
genuinely nice
so
i think a lot of girls are afraid
because you know they've been the nice
person in the past and maybe they've
gotten taken advantage of but
don't let one person take away from who
you are like your character so let me
know in the comments if you guys agree
or you disagree don't forget to
subscribe to the channel bring that
notification bell i'll talk to you guys
next time